in this morning's money watch we're
going to unpack what the debt ceiling
means to Everyday Americans with the
government expected to hit that limit
today when you hear the term debt
ceiling you might roll your eyes and
think to yourself how does this affect
me well CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to explain why it
actually does good morning how you doing
good good doing well okay so what
exactly is debt ceiling so it's
basically the limit and it's an
arbitrary limit of the total amount of
debt that the U.S can actually borrow
goes back to 1917. okay and because we
generally spend more than we take in
every year for all the various
obligations we have we run up debt
periodically the debt ceiling needs to
be raised it's been raised 86 times
since 1960. it's usually a bipartisan
non-event administrative but what is
clear is not raising the debt ceiling
can have significant consequences on the
economy and on us so I'm sitting at home
I'm watching you I should be worried why
well okay
okay when we don't have the debt ceiling
raised the
Treasury Department has a series of bad
decisions to make so right now they're
starting with kind of like the medium
measures that don't really impact us but
we get closer to the summer what is
likely to happen is we could start
seeing a real change what would happen
we could see furloughing of government
employees so now we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of people we're
talking about some of those government
employees being forced to work but not
getting paid we're also talking about
things like delaying Social Security
checks maybe you won't get your tax
refund on time maybe you won't go to a
national park I just want to focus on
one thing very particularly when you
don't have Social Security checks coming
in not only is it putting individuals at
risk it is putting the economy at risk
those Social Security checks are spent
in this economy we are in an economy
right now that is teetering on the edge
of recession so this could cause
tremendous tumult and could push us
further into tour recession than we
would have been otherwise the ripple
effect when you lay it out like that Joe
you go well why not just raise a dead
sealer right good thank you when you lay
it out like that yes thank you I exactly
agree with that because this has become
a strange battle in fighting a fight
that's already been fought and what do I
mean by that when you think about the
debt ceiling this is not running up new
debt for something we haven't voted on
Congress previous congresses Republicans
and Democrats have voted on certain
spending measures raising the debt
ceiling pays for the measures that have
already been been voted on okay so this
has become this strange way of saying we
don't like the amount of money going out
for Social Security or whatever program
you care or don't care it was already
agreed upon it was already agreed upon
which makes people like me nuts
Republicans want to use this moment
though to cut spending they say look the
debt ceiling is at 31 trillion that's a
huge number I mean on the other hand
feel better about your personal credit
do they have a point in saying hey this
is out of control well I think they
would have a point if they hadn't voted
back you know in 2017 for tax cuts that
weren't paid for or hadn't voted on a
series of plans that we really did need
during the pandemic you know everything
in retrospect gets a different tint
through a political lens I'm a money
person I don't really care about
politics I care when politicians screw
up the economy and actually impact
ordinary Americans lives that should be
your like uh answering machine messages
that's it right there money person
that's it that's it and and you know
what to be honest with you the people
who were grandstanding around this they
do so at their own Peril because in the
past what we know is when we have these
conflicts and they go to The Bitter End
just go back to 2011 the last time we
had a big impasse the stock market went
down by 14 percent over four weeks the
bond market went berserk and borrowing
costs increase we were looking at Job
losses and it did take time to recover
again we're already slowing down after
this post-pandemic recovery this is not
the moment to have a fight like this all
right all right very clear Phil always
breaks it down thank you Joe thanks